[Music]
cliff is with us in Reno Nevada hi cliff
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I ok I'm 67 I
basically a baby step 3 I and my dad
gave me $50,000 worth of gold I don't
know what to do with it and you've got
ours or gold certificates or what
well gold bars in Wyoming's Wow
okay all right well I would just
research someone in the area that is a
broker for that that sells them and and
I would check your spot price just jump
online and see what spot prices on gold
today I don't know what I've stopped my
head meaning what is it worth an ounce
the coins actually might be worth more
as coins than the gold spot prices per
ounce okay and so I'm just going to
become an expert in what the value of
what you're holding is and then be
looking for some place to liquidate and
I definitely would liquidate it okay
that's a big part of my question I am
yeah my going to be you know $50,000
shows up in my bank account is the
government going to we have any special
interest in a matter no did you receive
did you receive these bars and so forth
upon his death no no okay
and he's 89 and his fate is health is
kind of fading so yeah okay
[Music]
technically an individual gives another
individual more than $15,000 this year
it is taxable on gift tax to your dad
okay so when did he give you this money
it was just two weeks ago okay all right
is your mom life no are you married no
okay well I would back date that and
have him give you 15,000 worth
last year and December 31st and another
15,000 now and then another 15,000 next
year I mean you can hold it in your
possession but I would just set up a
gifting thing and you might want to see
a tax person to verify how to do this
proper wait a minute wait a minute wait
a moment
no no no no we don't need to do that you
do if if this does show up if you don't
do this properly you're he's gonna get
hammered with the gift tax anything over
15,000 is gonna get taxed okay okay if
they if they really got in and did an
audit and caught you and wore you out
they probably won't okay but the proper
way to do this is to have him fill out a
form with his income tax and and write
this down he needs to see his tax guy
and he needs to file a form that he gave
you this $50,000 gift under the unified
estate tax credit unified estate tax
credit okay I'm assuming he does not
have a 20 million dollar or greater net
worth right right okay then he can use
some of his estate credit that would
apply to his estate while he's alive and
not have to pay gift tax that's what
we're doing
but it's one piece of paper and he
absolutely needs to file it it's up to
him he's got to do it okay but it's he's
basically filing a gift tax return and
claiming that he gave you a $50,000 gift
you have zero taxes at all either way
you have zero taxes but they could come
back after him or his estate for taxes
on anything in excess of 15,000 if he
doesn't file this unified estate tax
credit form and claim this gift under
that there's an exemption where he does
not have to pay the gift tax but he
needs to file the form otherwise they
could technically hammering honestly I'd
say there's a 90 something percent
chance they never find it they never do
it but if I were in his shoes I still
would do it properly just for sleeping
at nights sake right yeah
well yeah it makes me wonder would it
just be better for me to hold on to the
gold until he passes well then it would
be under his it really is one form I
mean it's not he has to file an income
tax anyway and so they might as well
just file the one form and do it right
it's not that big a deal but um but yeah
you're not they're not going to come
through some kind of big investigation
on you it's not it's not you know it's
not like you're raising a red flag or
something but you know if he wants to
give it to you as part of your
inheritance upon his death he can do
that but you know you know technically
it you're holding it until that you're
holding his gold until he leaves it to
you as an inheritance you can do that
too that's fine I wouldn't do that
because I'd want to get this liquidated
because gold is so volatile and it's
such a bad investment I mean if he lives
five years there's no telling what the
change in value could be and so I'd want
to go ahead and get it done and done
right if it were me but you do with it
whatever you want hey man thanks for the
call